you know what and you'd figure oh also
by the way hey Nona mwah Wow guys this
is a conversation this is my show drop
now sitting with a couple of funniest
people on the planet now he knows you
too right the [ __ ] I do know so now if
you were just gonna tell like a story or
something yeah maybe he'd say all right
I'm gonna sit over here I'm gonna have a
smoke break a little while or are you
gonna come up with something that makes
no sense it's just it's not relevant
that they deserve
yeah but it talks it in dude dude what
you took a [ __ ] bowl of spaghetti and
yet dumped it out onto that baseball on
the team yeah and and the reason why I
say that is you might be like oh that
makes no sense
yeah that's exactly my point no what you
do yeah makes knows your this is my show
you took a bullet pasta you're
interrupting it into the [ __ ]
baseball no no and now and now as you're
explaining it to him he's saying no I
understand and it won't happen again and
he's got a bucket of chocolate ice cream
and he's dumping it on to the pot and
I'm asking it into the plate with his
foot while he's telling you I know that
I dropped this brother pasta on the
ground dude but at least maybe we could
pick tell me about the model have some
okay I was all I was gonna say was that
I went down there and it was very very
dark and I still got recognized of
course that didn't happen of course not
had it been in the moment that you were
doing it could have been amusing could
have been funny
not only that could have lead it led to
some other stuff yeah isn't that right
can it now no it can't get it so what
did we learn
Bry I not join you're putting your hands
in your lap I'm not your [ __ ] student
you guys are my guests I'm uncomfortable
with the fact I'm here sitting here in
the tea phadke studios the the show has
been so successful that when you know
your shows been successful when your
logo has been turned into some sort of
like bathroom
family you know that what ours there's
so many incarnations that new you know
what I will say what if they were very
successful
this wouldn't be broken I got a stick up
for Brian here that is that is the style
yeah that's not fair dude you're being
unfair right now it's broken like all
those are not those let's like a tile
work things it's our thing yeah yeah no
it's not broken
but I'll tell you I'll tell you if
you've got a studio where there's all
sorts of there's a really cool like what
would this be steampunk
this would be I made us that clock a guy
sent us a guy sent you that claw yes no
I didn't know you knew Gargamel it's a
little goth yes it's pretty cool I think
I saw yeah [ __ ] boring it isn't that
crazy I saw this clock in a Rammstein
video 94 but you've got all sorts of
cool stuff in here that tells everybody
that you guys are established and it's a
it's a very successful podcast and still
you know little about combo and then
crazy right that's so crazy no broken
glass side collage as my whole life [ __ ]
was that Brides career all you're gonna
think unless you're [ __ ] knocked over
one of this you ain't it better than
that no this is better look at the way
he's sitting this is better come on
look at the way he's [ __ ] sitting
there so I got a guy man
you you sit cover your [ __ ] for real
[ __ ] it don't don't sit like that Gaza
yes it's so lumpy comfy so disrespectful
is this it's respectful because I'm
using like you we've got me and I'm
being all as much of me as I can be no
I'm further soften it up here oh
reasonably brines videoing this when
there's seven cameras in here that's
pretty [ __ ] do I have to do that yeah
all right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch
your tongue oh good what's gonna happen
what are you gonna do use some of that
boxing you've been doing
[ __ ]